[Musique]
avec un million de postes vacants au
pays les employeurs ouvre comme jamais
la porte aux jeunes travailleurs ils
veulent les attirer les garder les
comprendre qu'est ce qui motive donc les
14 à 30 ans qu'est ce qui est important
pour les 14 à 30 ans dans le marché du
travail aujourd'hui en 2022 avec nous ce
soir catherine légaré présidente
fondatrice d'academos un organisme qui
s'intéresse de près à la génération z
bonsoir
vous publier un rapport sur les attentes
des jeunes c'est la troisième édition de
votre rapport est-ce que la pandémie a
changé la perception du travail et les
valeurs des jeunes par rapport à leur
future carrière
oui je vais prendre un instant pour
peut-être dire ce qu on fait chacun des
morceaux puis pourquoi on a fait ce sera
pas en jeu donc chez academos on est un
organisme à but non lucratif on aide les
gens à faire leur choix de carrière
entre autres avec une plateforme de
mentorat où les jeunes peuvent avoir un
contact directement avec des
travailleurs de toutes sortes de métiers
profession il ya 150 mais le jeune en ce
moment le pire on compte sur cette
plateforme la note 3000 mentor donc bien
entendu nous on veut savoir toujours
comme envier répondre à ces jeunes là
donc c'est pour ça qu'on fait un rapport
comme ça pour une troisième année mais
bien entendu mais on se dit ça aide les
employeurs à mieux comprendre les jeunes
qui arrivent dans leur milieu de travail
et puis tu arrêtes tous les intervenants
en fait qui travaille auprès de ces
jeunes là qu'on a découvert des
résultats si je pardonne et a tout de
suite ses quais
l'objectif numéro 1 des jeunes dans un
choix de carrière s'est trouvé un emploi
qui valait les nourrir qui va leur
permettre de s'épanouir
donc c'est ce qu'ils recherchent en
premier le soin dans un choix de
carrière ou dans un emploi qu'ils vont
occuper et la pandémie est ce que ça a
changé leur le regard sur le marché du
travail et leurs attentes
et oui il ya certaines choses qui ont
changé par exemple l'an 2019 quand on
avait posé un peu cette question-là sur
les éléments et partant dans un choix de
carrière on avait beaucoup des réponses
les premières réponses étaient en lien
avec l'épanouissement ça s'était
toujours en famille mais après les
jeunes par le plaisir au travail de
bien-être au travail
cette année la nouveauté c'est qu'en
deuxième position b c des préoccupations
d'argent que les jeunes ont donc ils
veulent un emploi qui va leur permettre
de subvenir aux besoins à leurs besoins
à eux et aux besoins de leur famille
donc ce dépôt vu dans le rapport
précédent ce qui laisse à votre
économie
parce qu'ils veulent devenir riche
non c'est pas devenir riche en fait il
nuance c'est vraiment répondre à ses
besoins répondre aux besoins de sa
famille pouvoir payer ses factures et
tous à devenir riche c'est iain marboeuf
donc tous qui riche s prestige montée on
ira chez dans une entreprise c'est
beaucoup moins important pour eux là que
l'épanouissement à prendre se développer
ils viennent entendu le nra ces patients
est ce que vous diriez qu'ils n'ont pas
beaucoup d'ambition si on associe le mot
ambitions à gravir des échelons ou à
réussir sur le plan professionnel ou
même financiers
je dirais pas ça parce que si on regarde
le premier élément pour eux c'est
l'épanouissement au travail
l'épanouissement personnel je pense
quelle ambition elle est simplement
différente
donc il veut se développer elle va
l'apprendre il va se sentir utile ça va
probablement les amener à gravir des
échelons mais c'est pas l'angle sous
lequel ils prennent une chose parce que
l'entrepreneur iode tentent ces jeunes
de 14 à 30 ans
oui c'est dans l'est on a fait un top
des métiers l'entrepreneuriat est en
quatrième place donc probablement encore
une fois pour les jeunes chercheurs
l'autonomie cherche à s'épanouir
chercheurs avant de l'impact sentiment
d'utilité souvent c'est ce qu'on peut
percevoir de l'entrepreneuriat alors ça
pourrait expliquer cet engouement pour
l'entrepreneuriat cela dit ben ali trois
premières positions sont des mythiques
on connait tous le l'enseignement
l'amitié ils veulent devenir ingénieur
donc ils veulent beaucoup faire des
métiers que qu'on connaît qu'on connaît
tous est ce qu'ils veulent devenir
infirmiers infirmières
enseignants et enseignantes ce sont des
secteurs qui sont identifiés par le
gouvernement du québec comme étant des
secteurs critiques de l'économie tout à
fait tout à fait alors il répondra seul
as conjugue aussi avec un sentiment
d'utilité c'est ce qu'on avait vu dans
notre deuxième rapport l'année dernière
il y avait comme un mouvement vers des
métiers qui ont du sens les gens m'ont
vu leurs parents travailler à la maison
pendant la pandémie à leur taille ont vu
leurs parents perdent leur emploi
également donc ça fait réfléchir il y en
a le corps d'ailleurs qui ont changé de
choix carrière depuis le début de la
pandémie donc ils se sont peut-être
centrée sur des choses qui ont du sens
pour eux qui sont en lien avec leurs
valeurs qui vont leur permettre de
s'épanouir donc des secteurs comme la
santé l'éducation
facilement parce qu'ils sont anxieux
face au choix de leur carrière future
oui ils sont anxieux ont fait notre
rapport concorde avec beaucoup d'autres
enquêtes qui sont sortis récemment sur
l'anxiété des jeunes donc au regard de
leur choix de carrière c'est la même
chose on a près de la moitié de nos gens
qui se disent assez attrayant monsieur
s'est beaucoup attaché bien entendu au
fait prendre une décision qui est
souvent la plus importante qu'ils ont
prises dans leur vie logica maintenant
ils sont assez jeunes auraient pendant
le ces des jeunes de 14 à 30 ans donc
puis la capacité à anticiper aussi ce
qui va se passer dans le marché du
travail donc pour ce que de l'autre côté
les jeunes nous disent aussi à 51% que
le moyen qui trouve le plus utile pour
les aider dans leur choix de carrière
mais c'est d'être un contact concret
avec le monde voilà donc par des mentors
comme ce qu'on fait chaque à des morts
ou des stages ou des visites
d'entreprises ouvrage d'un jour c'est
c'est ce qui lie ses skis les connecte
du concret avec l'offre professionnelle
très intéressant catherine légaré merci
d'avoir été avec nous merci merci à vous
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit